donc nous voyons il el brun Pivet et
Gérard Larcher qui vont donc rejoindre
la tête de cortège de cette marche
aujourd'hui marche civique pour la
République il se trouve actuellement
devant les colonades de l'Assemblée
nationale côté donc kedorset au tout
début du boulevard Saint-Germain pour
une sorte de photo qui va réunir toute
la la tête de cortège devrait se trouver
sur cette photo Nicolas Sarkozi François
Hollande un certain nombre de de
ministres vous aper ev Olivier du sopte
le ministre du Travail quelques 25
ministres
on leur présence à cette manifestation
Jean-Louis Debré Jonathan harfy aussi
qui se trouve là donc pour le Conseil
représentant des des Juifs de France
jean-mar ho l'ancien Premier ministre
socialiste de François Hollande
d'ailleurs les deux anciens présidents
de la République François Hollande et
Nicolas Sarkozi devrait également
participer à à cette photo de et donc
Philippe l'ancien Premier ministre qui
se trouve également sur C le ministre de
B avec le
Parlement on voit également Roland
lescur et Bruno Le Maire voilà une
partie du gouvernement 25 ministres sont
attendus au sein Elisabeth borne qui se
trouve aussi sur sur ces images bien sûr
au côté de Gérard Larcher de de François
Hollande il y a elbron Pivet qui
s'entretient avec la première ministre
quelques minutes avant le début C
ber qui sont également présents sur
cette cette photo donc rassemblement
pour pour la
République corcia le grand Rabin de
France également présent donc plusieurs
représentants des des cultes qui se
trouvent aussi à cette à cette marche
Jonath Jonathan ah voilà Nicolas sarzy
aussi est on voit François Hollande
également qui est présent également
l'ancien président socialiste du du
Sénat Jean-Pierre Bell au 2e rang
derrière Jard Larcher Jonathan Ayoun
c'est un symbole fort de voir toutes ces
personnalités sur ces personnalités
politiques de premier plan d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui toutes ces personnalités
des institutions juives ensemble sur ses
marches devant l'Assemblée dans
l'histoire des Juifs de France c'est
quand même quelque chose de très
important parce qu'il veut tout de même
rappeler que dans la longue histoire de
la présence des Juifs en France c'est à
l'Assemblée en
1791 que pour la première fois ils ont
été regardé comme les autres que pour la
PR prière fois ils sont devenus citoyens
c'est pas en 1789 au moment de la
déclaration de
1 Ju dans réassemblée vote la pleine
citoyenneté pour les Juifs donc cette
image là au regard de l'histoire elle a
de la force avec cette banderole avec un
message évidemment très fort pour la
République et contre l'antisémitisme
toutes ces ces personnalités politiques
qui se sont réunies et des cultes pour
dire non à ces actes antisémites qui se
multiplient sur le territoire français
depuis le 7 octobre dernier ouais moi je
trouve que c'est très fort c'est vrai
qu'on parle des citoyens parce que c'est
eux qui vont faire la manifestation et
c'est eux qui passent un petit peu
au-dessus des polémiques et des
problèmes et et tant mieux mais c'est
vrai que c'est fort de voir ses
représentants Unis moi je trouve qu'il y
a un petit manque il y en a un qui
manque voilà je dis et je le redis parce
que mine de rien les symboles et ces
imagesl elles sont très fortes et même
si demain ou ce soir on se dit 200000 ou
je sais pas combien et ça marquera le
coup c'est vrai que d'avoir ses
représentants et franchement on on le
ressent il y a quelque chose de l'ordre
de l'émotion et de et de de la cohésion
d'une unité qui dépasse un petit peu
l'éclivage et ça c'est
important